MARLA: I'm an engineer at
the Cultural Institute.
And you should have been on a
tour of the Cultural Institute
earlier today, so you
probably know a bit about it.
But basically, we are
a team of engineers
whose mission is to
democratize access to culture.
And one of the ways we do
that is by helping museums
digitize their collections.
So that's why we built
the Art Camera, which
is this thing right here.
And it's a camera to
digitize paintings
in very high resolution.
And also, efficiently
at low cost.
So it works by
taking automatically
hundreds of very zoomed
in pictures of an artwork.
And then, we stitch all
these pictures together
to make a single very
high resolution image.
We call these images gigapixels,
because they typically
contain a few billion pixels.
So that's one example.
That's one of the
first paintings we
digitized with the Art Camera.
It's by a street artist,
called [INAUDIBLE].
And if you zoom in, here
is the kind of resolution
that we can get.
So here, you can see
details that you would not
be able to see with
your naked eye.
So we actually get better
than eye resolution.
And if you were to display this
at 100 pixels per inch, which
is a typical display resolution,
then it would be about 10
by 15 meters.
So that's the kind of thing we
can get with the Art Camera.
And now, let me tell
you a bit about what
it's like for me
working on this project.
So I joined this project
about 10 months ago.
And when I first
joined, it was a bit
like the first time I saw this.
I was like, what is this?
It's a big project with
lots of moving parts.
There's three main components.
The first component is the
camera itself, the hardware.
So the actual DSLR camera
is an off the shelf Canon
camera with a custom enclosure.
And there's also
inside a custom circuit
board with custom firmware.
Then, the camera is
controlled by software
running on a laptop.
That's connected to USB.
So on the laptop, there's
eight different servers
running to control the
camera and also web
UI for the operator.
And the third part is
the stitching pipeline.
So the software actually pieces
all the pictures together
to create a single image.
And that doesn't
run on the laptop.
That runs in Google
data centers.
And the pipeline
looks like this.
So I was like, what?
And all of this is written
using some C, lots of C++.
Quite a lot of Python.
There's a bit of Java.
There's HTML and JavaScript.
And CSS of course.
So it's lots of moving pieces.
And what's also fun
about this project
is that we're just two software
engineers working on it.
So that means we all get
to work on everything.
Also, my colleague joined
the project 12 months ago
and I joined 10 months ago.
And it's just been
the two of us since.
And that means that
we don't have anybody
to ask questions to when we
don't know how things work.
Or why they work that way.
Or is there really a
good reason for that?
Because sometimes there isn't.
And so, it's always a
bit of a detective story
when we try to
investigate issues.
Another fun part of the project
is working with hardware.
So that's me working
with hardware.
One of the things when
you work with hardware
is that you can't just write
unit tests for your software.
At some point,
you really do have
to test with the actual camera
by plugging these things
physically.
We do have unit tests and
integration tests that
use a fake software camera.
But recently for
instance, I wrote a bug
and that went into production.
And we didn't notice,
because the bug was only
happening in the real camera
and not in the fake one.
Because we discovered
that there was
a difference between the
fake camera the real one.
And we were not aware
of that difference.
So these things happen.
That's why you have to
test with a camera and even
with several cameras and
different situations.
Another fun part
with hardware is
that these cameras get sent
all over the world to museums.
And sometimes things
get wrong at the museum.
And then, we have to
try and de-bug remotely.
So recently, I had to
SSH into an Art Camera
laptop in Columbia to try
and help with a capture that
wasn't going well.
And the connection
kept dropping,
so that was lots of fun.
But now, I understand
this project a bit better.
So I can run you through
how a capture happens,
how we get to this gigapixel.
So this is the basic flow.
First, we ship the
camera to the museum.
Then, we set it up
for each painting.
Then, we capture the painting.
We upload the data to
Google Data Centers,
where we stitch everything.
And then, we are ready
to publish it on the web.
Each step in a bit more detail.
So first, we center the
camera on the painting.
And at this step, we also decide
what distance to put the camera
from the painting.
There's a trade-off.
The closer the camera is to
the artwork, the more pixels
we get.
The better resolution.
But also the more time it
takes, because it means
we need to take more pictures.
And you should be
able to see here.
To help with the distance,
we have a sonar here
that tells us the
distance to the painting.
The second step is
capturing the color checker.
So that's a really
important step.
The color checker is this
object that you see on the left.
It's a piece of plastic
with patches of color
that have very precise
predefined colors.
And taking a picture
of this object
allows us to record what
the lighting in the room
was like when we
captured the painting.
So that's really
important, because when
you take a picture
with a camera,
the RGB values of the pixels
depend not on the object
that you photographed,
but also on the lighting.
And so, taking a picture of
this and recording lighting
allows us afterwards to
apply a correction algorithm
to the colors of
the picture to make
it look like all the
artworks were captured
under the same
lighting conditions,
even though that's
not necessarily true.
Third step is the
actual capture.
So the camera stays fixed, but
it can rotate left and right
and up and down with this.
Which is called a gimbal and
there's two [? buttons. ?]
And so, it
automatically takes as I
said, hundreds of pictures.
This shows you the
pictures that we
would take for an artwork that's
about one meter wide at two
meters distance.
So that's roughly 1000 pictures.
And it would take about an hour.
Once we have all this
data, we upload it.
And then, we put it in
the stitching pipeline.
So I showed the diagram
of the program earlier.
It's kind of complicated.
But the basic idea
is that we first look
for features in all the images.
So features are points of
interest on the images, things
that we can describe,
like edges or corners.
And they're represented
by squares on this slide.
And then, we try
to match features
between neighboring images.
So if you find this
corner in an image
and we find the same corner
in another image, we say OK.
That's probably the same point.
And then, after we matched
all of these features,
we can find the best
alignment for the images.
And then, we can blend
them smoothly together,
so that you don't see the
separation between the images.
So after this step, we
have one single big image.
Which, for instance for the
painting I showed earlier,
is about 500 megabytes.
So at this point,
there's still a step
needed to put it on the web.
Because we don't want users to
have to download 500 megabytes
just to see one painting.
So what we do is that
we slice it up in tiles.
So we cut it into square tiles
that are 512 pixels by 512.
And we also made smaller
versions of the painting
with fewer tiles.
Until at the top of the pyramid,
you only have a single tile.
A thumbnail of the image.
And so, that way when the user
navigates the image-- like pans
around and zooms
in, we only need
to load the ties that
are needed to show
the part of the painting
that the user is looking at,
at the current zoom level.
So that's how capture works.
So now, I'm going to tell you
a bit about specific change
I've been working on.
So that you know what
I'm actually working on.
And that change is the
quest for sharp pixels.
Trying to get the
sharpest pictures we can.
As I explained, we take hundreds
of pictures of the painting.
And most of the
time, they're sharp.
But also, sometimes
we notice that we
have some that are blurry,
which is obviously bad.
Because we're not getting
the best quality we could.
And also then, when we
stitch them together,
you can see the separation
between the sharp picture
and the blurry picture.
So that doesn't look very good.
And sometimes we
actually fail to stitch.
Because when we try to match
the features between the images,
the images don't look like
each other because one is sharp
and one is blurry.
So the idea was to try and
detect automatically when
we took a blurry picture,
so that we can immediately
take another one.
And trying to evaluate
the sharpness of a picture
is quite a common problem.
There's actually lots of
research papers on it.
So I read a bunch
of papers and I also
looked around other
Google projects
to see what they were doing,
because I'm not the first one
to try and determine if
an image is blurry or not.
And I got all the data set
of some of our sharp pictures
and some of our blurry pictures.
And I tried these
algorithms on it.
And actually none of them
worked very well on my data sets
and there are several reasons.
One reason is I think most of
these algorithms work better
on out of focus blur.
So basically there are two
reasons why you can get blur.
One is because your
object is out of focus,
so your camera is
focused in front
or in the back of your object.
And the other is
the motion blur,
because you moved
the camera while you
were taking the picture.
And actually, it seems that
most of the blur we get
is from motion blur.
I mean the camera is not moving.
But actually, we're
taking pictures
that are so zoomed in that even
the tiniest shake of the camera
causes blur.
That's the kind of blur
that's a bit harder to detect.
And another thing that makes
it a bit more complicated
is the fact that we have some
pictures that look like this.
So when we are
capturing a drawing
and there's like the drawing
in the middle and on the sides,
it's just paper, we have
pictures that look like paper.
And most algorithms
will say, oh.
That's pretty blurry.
But actually, it's a sharp
picture of a piece of paper.
And even for me when I
was getting my data set
and trying to find sharp
pictures and blurry pictures,
sometimes it was hard for me to
tell if they were sharp or not.
So if it's hard for
me, you can tell
it's going to be tricky
for an algorithm.
So at that point, I
was a bit disappointed
that it didn't work.
And then, my colleagues
came to my rescue
and give me a
million suggestions.
There were more possibilities
than combinations
on my Rubik's cube.
And I was like, ah!
I can't test all of this.
I mean I could
spend months trying
to-- I'm sure this is a
problem that can be solved.
I could spend months
trying to solve it.
But actually, at that point, I
thought that a better approach
would be to try and
prevent the shaking
or the blur from happening
in the first place.
So why are we getting
blurry pictures?
I said it's because of shaking.
So how do you get
rid of shaking?
Typically, a photographer
would tell you, well, you
use a tripod.
So we already have a
very sturdy tripod.
It's very big and heavy.
But the fact that we take
pictures that are so zoomed in
means when it's shaking a tiny
bit-- and you can't even see.
Like I look at it and I'm
like, it's not shaking.
But actually, it is.
When you look at the camera
view, it is shaking a bit.
And so we are getting
blurry pictures,
despite this very heavy
industrial tripod.
So what we can do is try
and use an accelerometer
to detect when the
camera is moving.
And we actually already
have an accelerometer
on the camera that
was already there.
On that custom board
that I mentioned.
And we have an algorithm that's
supposed to detect shaking
and prevent taking
pictures when it's shaking.
So if we already have this, why
am I getting blurry pictures?
That was the question
I asked myself.
Obviously, the shaking
detection algorithm
was not working very well,
because we got blurry pictures
even though it said it's fine.
And also, sometimes when we
were in museums, the shaking
the detection was saying
all the time, oh my god.
It's shaking, I can't
take a picture--
even though everything
seemed fine.
And when I had to SSH in
Columbia-- that story I
mentioned earlier-- that was
because of a shaking problem.
It kept saying it was
shaking, so the operator
could not capture, even
though everything seemed fine.
So I didn't know anything
about accelerometers
or signal processing
or anything.
And as I said, there
was nobody on the team
who knew anything about this.
So I dug up the schematics
of the power board
and the data sheet
of the accelerometer.
And I spent hours trying
to understand what
the firmware was trying to do.
And then, finally I wrote some
tools to record some data.
So on the left, I recorded
the camera images,
so that I could see visually if
it looked like it was shaking.
And on the right, you have
the accelerometer data.
So there's three lines
for x, y, and z-axes.
And so, after looking at
this data, what I realized
is that probably we were
giving too much importance
to high frequencies and not
enough to low frequencies.
And so, I try and
modified the algorithm
to have a low pass
filter to remove
the very high frequencies,
which are just noise.
Which are not
actually causing blur.
So that we can detect
the lower frequencies,
which actually cause blur.
So that's not really
the end of the story,
because I'm still
working on this.
I haven't deployed
the new version yet,
because that's the fun
thing we have where I said,
you have to test it a lot.
I have to test it on
different cameras,
because maybe they vibrate
at different frequencies
and in different conditions.
Maybe here at my
desk, it's fine.
Maybe in Columbia it's not fine.
Maybe I won't go
test it in Columbia.
But it needs a lot more testing.
So to summarize working
on this project,
it's fun and challenging.
And sometimes it's
also frustrating.
But at the same time,
it's very rewarding
because at the end of
all this hard work,
we have several
thousand pictures
for very high resolution
pictures of paintings
that we've captured.
And that we have
available on the web
at google.com/CulturalInstitute.
So you can go check
them out over there.
And sometimes you also get
very nice messages from users,
so that's really gratifying.
And that really makes
it worth the effort.
Thank you.
Questions?
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
MARLA: Hello.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I saw that there is,
it's a camera inside,
so I guess it has a brand.
Did you happen to work with
the brand of this camera?
I mean all these algorithms
to improve this camera?
Or with the company
that built this camera?
MARLA: The actual DSLR
camera that's inside
is an off the shelf camera.
So it's a normal camera
that you can buy.
It's a Canon camera.
It's a 7D Mark II if you know
anything about photography.
I didn't know anything
about photography
before joining this
project by the way.
I learned some stuff.
Now, I know some stuff.
We also have a professional
photographer that helps us.
And that goes to
museums sometime.
So that also helps.
But, yeah.
It's a normal camera.
And I think this model is
working pretty well for us
right now.
I'm not sure if that was
exactly your question.
AUDIENCE: Basically,
did you think about
to work with the camera
company that built this Canon?
Or with Canon?
I don't know.
Because I guess they
have more experience
about building cameras.
MARLA: Yeah.
I guess that's a good question.
So I think we're happy
with the camera itself.
And like the value
we're adding is not--
the way we're getting very
high resolution images
is not by having the
best camera in the world
that has the most
pixels in the world.
It's by just having
a normal camera
and taking lots of pictures.
And then, stitching
them all together.
And we also wanted it to be a
normal camera, because we don't
want this to be too expensive.
We want it to be low
cost and efficient.
AUDIENCE: OK.
MARLA: Is there
another question?
Over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
MARLA: Hi.
AUDIENCE: So what
is your technique
to stitch correctly the
different images that you're
taking?
MARLA: So I tried to explain
that quickly at one point.
So we know where we
took the images, right?
Because we know where the
camera was pointing at.
And you would think we could
just use that information.
But actually, it's
not precise enough.
So the way we do it
is actually looking
at the pixels of the images.
So we take images
that overlap a little.
So each area is
on several images
and then we check
for these overlaps.
And we figure out what's the
best alignment for the images
and how best to stitch them.
I hope that makes
it a bit clearer.
I'm not sure if that's the case.
AUDIENCE: So can you tell us
how many pictures on average
do you take for each artwork?
And do you have a paper
explaining the algorithm
of the stitching part?
MARLA: I don't know
the average number.
It's probably on average
between 500 and 1,000.
We don't have a paper or
anything explaining it.
If you guys want to learn more
about it, you can email me.
My address is Marla, my
first name, @google.com.
Because I don't really
have time right now
to explain everything in detail.
Also, I don't know
the most about it.
The one who knows
the most about it
is my colleague, the other
engineer who works on it.
But really, it's a bunch
of existing techniques
like looking for features.
There are algorithms that
exist to look for features.
Matching features
is just features
that are described by vectors.
We just look for the Euclidean
distance of the vectors
and things like that.
No.
We don't use machine learning.
Not that I know, but maybe.
I think I might have time.
AUDIENCE: The final question.
MARLA: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Did you finish
that Rubik's cube as you
were standing up on stage?
[CHUCKLING]
[APPLAUSE]